Sonne have said that they were surprised  with how well blood-borne sold despite  the fact that they already had pretty  high expectations for its success sony  UK marketing manager Fergal gara told  MCV quote we had expectations to do well  we looked at the sole series as a frame  of reference and we thought we could do  better than that we did and then some  relative to some of our sister  territories we were being quite  ambitious but even that proved to be  conservative  Gauri suggested that blood-borne success  could have been due to its good timing  given it came out in a relatively slow  release period Paul nurse specific sales  numbers have been shed Sony did mention  last month that blood-borne had exceeded  1 million copies sold to customers  worldwide let me know if you got hooked  into blood-borne and which other  currents and console games you're  looking forward to playing this year  we'll keep you updated on all the latest  news on Game five so be sure to stay  tuned